ich möchte eigentlich von dieser
beschäftigung mit dem bösen ein bisschen
wegkommen ich habe jetzt hier so ein
buch theorien des bösen gründe des bösen
über das böse also irgendwann ist auch
mal genug mit diesem lösen und jetzt
soll es mal um das moralische gehen
warum die rede von dem bösen ist einfach
sehr problematisch und das aus vielerlei
gründen möchte ein paar gründe angeben
warum die rede von dem bösen schwierig
ist ich habe im letzten jahr zu glauben
im vorletzten jahr hier mal ein vortrag
gehalten
der ging nur um das böse und da hatte
ich darauf hingewiesen dass wir die rede
von den bösen auch noch unterscheiden
müssen sprechen wir von dem bösen groß
geschrieben also substantiiert das böse
oder sprechen wir von dem von böse im
sinne des klein geschriebenen adjektiv
das prädikat dass wir etwas
qualifizieren und nicht essentially
sieren das ist schon ein großes problem
aber das überhaupt so etwas möglich ist
das hängt natürlich mit diesem begriff
des bösen zusammen und ich sage es
problematisch aus verschiedenen gründen
einmal er ist extrem normativ ein sehr
starker begriff das ist ein problem dann
ein weiteres problem er ist vieldeutig
als wir können unterscheiden zwischen
dem natürlichen bösen und dem
moralischen bösen können bestimmt noch
verschiedenen anderen hinsichten
unterscheiden also sie kennen das wenn
man jetzt mit kindern spricht oder auch
anderen menschen das gesagt das war böse
das tut weh das ist etwas was schmerz
erzeugt da wird dann auch häufig gesagt
das ist böse oder jemand böses ist
jemand einfach der ja auch letztendlich
auszuschalten ist alle das geht dann
auch wenn diese richtung dass dieses
wort leicht missbraucht werden kann wenn
man von einer achse des bösen spricht
also dass ein diskriminierungs begriff
durchaus also er lässt sich so
jedenfalls missbrauchen
ich sage nicht dass er damit überflüssig
ist aber er ist schwierig und er lässt
sich eben auch nur schwer rational
analysieren
es ist eine große große herausforderung
das zu versuchen ich habe es versucht
ich werde es auch in diesem vortrag ein
bisschen weiter versuchen das böse nicht
nur als etwas dunkles als eine dunkle
macht darzustellen die sich uns
prinzipiell verschließt und ich glaube
das böse ist nicht dunkel ist und das
böse besteht darin dass es für dunk hält
also das dunkle ist ein effekt des bösen
und das bedeutet gerade nicht dass das
böse selbst dunkel ist es erzeugt eben
dunkelheit und es hat einen eher als
analysierende struktur aber ich möchte
dennoch im heutigen vortrag wegkommen
etwas von dieser rede von dem bösen auch
häufig in fiktiven erzählungen auf das
spricht jetzt auch nicht per se gegen
den begriff sehr sinnvoll und begriffe
treten auch in fiktiven erzählungen auf
oder in schauergeschichten oder
sonstigen im märchen
also das entspricht per se noch nicht
gegen den begriff aber es macht ihn
zumindest problematisch und die könnte
man auch viele weitere punkte anführen
die zeigen dass ist ein problematischer
begriff ist es gibt einen philosophen
philipp kohl der hat ein buch
geschrieben mit dem titel damit auf ebay
2006 erschien und er sagt folgendes am
ende seines buches oder seine überlegung
sagte ein klotener die idee auf ebay ist
oder philosophische konzept sollten die
nordostecke logical konzept des ripley
in grant narrative south stream also
dieser begriff ist analytisch gar nicht
sinnvoll zu gebrauchen sagt ja ich würde
mich seinem urteil nicht anschließen
wollen weil ich glaube dass man im griff
tatsächlich noch weiter aufklären kann
aber ich denke man sollte diese fünf
etwas ernst nehmen und vielleicht
erstmal nur von unmoralischen sprechen
wenn man sich mit dem bösen beschäftigen
möchte also nicht gleich so stark
einzusteigen so hoch einzusteigen gleich
auf dieser stark normativen ebene so ein
bisschen unter heruntergestuft das ganze
zu betrachten und erstmal nur sagen
unmoralisch im weitesten sinne und dann
versuchen vom begriff des unmoralischen
der des kreativ mir weiter erschließbar
und auch etwas neutraler ist
wir müssen davon ausgehen dann das
phänomen des bösen versuchen zu
erschließen
also nicht gleich voller einsatz erst
noch ein bisschen herunterstufen das
ganze das unmoralisch ist lebensweltlich
alltäglich und vertraut jeder würde
sagen dass er kleine sünden begeht das
ist auch erst mal gar nicht so schlimm
wie das böse wäre würde man sich schon
sagen dass er böse ist obwohl immanuel
kant ja gesagt hat dass wir radikal
bösen sind also dass das radikal böse
gibt einen hang zum bösen wenn auch noch
zugleich eine anlage zum guten aber das
ist jedenfalls ein starke begriff wird
gehen hier auf so moralisch ersten 1
und hier gibt es ein paar schöne
beispiele
sie kennen sicherlich von peter breuer
diese dieses diese sequenz über die
sieben laster hier ist jetzt die havarie
zia vorgestellt das ist jetzt der geiz
finde ich also sehr anschaulich auch
lebensweltlich irgendwie nachvollziehbar
hier eine frau die das geld zählen und
hier wird also geld ausgeschüttet hier
wird das geld akquiriert hier streben
alle danach diesen sack zum beispiel mit
geld hier mit pfeilen zu beschießen um
das geld zu vereinnahmen
das finde ich ganz schön lebens wirklich
ein phänomen und dann gibt es ja noch
den hochmut die superb da steht
natürlich dann diesen spiegel hier im
zentrum die suppe bia der hochmut aber
auch jetzt anders nennen eitelkeit
vielleicht auch so ein bisschen was das
ist jetzt sicherlich nicht das böse das
würden wir nicht sagen wir würden aber
sagen es ist es nicht vielleicht eine
besonders moralische einstellung wenn
wir diese tugenden sage jetzt mal diese
laster uns zu eigen machen wir sollten
sie eigentlich lassen es ist tendenziell
unmoralisch aber böse würden wir jetzt
so noch nicht sicherlich sagen also
lebens wirklich sind diese sachen uns
sehr gängig und sehr bekannt ich will
jetzt mal ein paar formen des
unmoralischen einfach mal nennen ohne
jetzt hier den anspruch auf
vollständigkeit zu erheben also was
gibt's denn alles an
moralischen zb lüge selbst lüge und
selbsttäuschung night egoismus
missachtung verachtung und arroganz
unterdrückung und entmenschlichung
rassismus verrat und treuebruch
instrumentalisierung fanatismus und
terrorismus und auch moralismus worüber
frau professor wetzlar in der jüngsten
zeit gearbeitet hat also auch gerade
wenn man die moral sehr groß schreibt
kann das auf eine art geschehen dass die
moral dadurch pervertierte das muss man
sich fragen warum ist das zu warum ist
moralismus gerade unmoralisch und so
weiter und so fort es gibt ja
verschiedene weitere formen noch jetzt
kann man sich fragen sind die alle
phänomene auf derselben ebene angesetzt
angesiedelt sicherlich nicht und sind
sie in ihrer ausprägung des
unmoralischen verschieden sicherlich ja
also jemand der terroristische
handlungen vollzieht ist sicherlich die
moralisch problematische als jemand der
an moralismus vertritt aber sie sehen
gleich terroristen sind häufig auch
moralisten ja also das kommt nicht aus
dem nichts sondern das sind besonders
radikalisierte menschen die eigentlich
glauben das gute zu tun
naja die tun das böse ja nicht und das
schlechte ja nicht bewusst sagen ja
nicht jetzt schon mal hier was böses das
wird in allerwenigsten fällen so sein
aber jetzt der bluesnight zb ist an sich
ein alltägliches phänomen kennt jeder
von ihnen
und da ist noch nicht gleich böse und
terrorist aber der neid kann sicherlich
so ein anfangs grund seien das was so
etwas wie moralismus auftrat dass wir
den anderen etwas nicht können und dann
versuchen moralische gründe anzuführen
dass der andere das jetzt nicht verdient
er hat nicht genug getan ich habe doch
viel mehr geschafft als er
und dann kann ich mich mit diesem leid
so sehr radikalisieren dass am ende eine
ganze ideologie ein fanatischer
terrorismus entsteht also sehen diese
phänomene sind voneinander abhängig und
es käme jetzt darauf an diese stufen des
unmoralischen
haben zusammenhang näher zu analysieren
das möchte ich jetzt hier nicht in
diesem vortrag machen das viel zu kurz
aber ich will nur zeigen es gibt hier
also eine durchlässigkeit und sonne
gegen seine gegenseitige verweisung
strukturen die sind alle miteinander
verbunden das ist so eine these von mir
als will ich jedenfalls noch mal kurz
auf aristoteles eingehend der hat hier
eine wichtige unterscheidung angebracht
zwischen der mäßigkeit der und der
unbeherrschtheit man jetzt kann man sich
fragen was ist jetzt der grund dieses
unmoralischen aristoteles sagt der
unmäßige der accola stores ist nicht
geeignet bedauern zu empfinden denn er
bleibt bei seinem vorsatz jeder
unbeherrschte accra tees hingegen
empfindet bedauern daher fehlte verhält
es sich nicht so wie wir bei der
darlegung der schwierigkeiten formuliert
haben
vielmehr ist der unmäßige unheilbar und
der unbeherrschte heilbar
es gleicht nämlich das laster
krankheiten wie der wasser sucht oder
der schwitzen die unbeherrschtheit
dagegen epileptischen anfällen denn die
einen die mäßigkeit ist eine ständig
vorhandene schlechtigkeit katia die
andere die unbeherrschtheit die andere
die unbeherrschtheit eine nicht ständig
vorhandene überhaupt gehören
unbeherrschtheit und schlechtigkeit zu
verschiedenen gattungen denen die
schlechtigkeit bleibt unbemerkt die
unbeherrschtheit hingegen nicht also
aristoteles sagt wir können verschiedene
formen unterscheiden und das
problematische phänomen ist die
schlechtigkeit über die unmäßigkeit die
ist so etwas was uns überhaupt nicht
mehr mitleid oder bedauern empfindet es
da sind wir so tief verstrickt darin
dass wir nicht mehr rauskommen und da
müsste man jetzt ansetzen bei der
unmäßigkeit oder bei der schlechtigkeit
kaka aber man muss da jetzt noch viel
weiter fragen also unbeherrschtheit
alleine ist es nicht dass es ihr etwas
äußerliches und wir wollen jetzt weiter
fragen was ist jetzt eigentlich der
grund dieser schlechtigkeit worin
besteht die und warum ist die
schlechtigkeit so dass wir dann darin
kein bedauern mehr empfinden können dass
wir zum beispiel auch unser mitleid
ausschalten können wir schalten das
mitleid nicht per knopfdruck aus sondern
es handelt sich hier um einen prozess
innerhalb dessen dann am ende so etwas
wie mitleid gar nicht mehr empfunden
werden kann
worin liegt also der grund des
unmoralischen wir müssen hier weiter
fragen als aristoteles ist tot scheint
mir wie kommen wir überhaupt dazu
unmoralisch zu handeln so dass wir dann
im sinne dieser kaka diese unmäßigkeit
dieser schlechtigkeit am ende kein
mitleid mehr empfinden können jetzt
immer hier erst mal dieses sokratische
paradox ernst nehmen weil wie ich schon
sagte im falle der terroristen wir tun
das üble das böse das unmoralische die
sehenden auges also es gibt da eine
stelle im platonischen werk wo der
sokrates sagt niemand geht aus freier
wahl den bösen nach kaka nach dem
schlechten oder dem was er verbüßte hält
das ist aus der schrift aus dem dialog
pythagoras ganz wichtig ist mir jetzt
hier
dass diese so karte so der plan der
platonische sokrates hier noch ein
nachsatz hat nämlich dem was er verbüßte
hält das ist in meinen augen das
entscheidende
es geht also nicht hier um das böse als
solches sondern es geht um das was man
für das böse hält genauso auch um das
was man für das gute hält kann auch
genauso andersrum formulieren
man geht demnach umgedreht formuliert
was man für das gute hält nicht
unbedingt das gute an sich also wie
kommt es jetzt dass wir böse oder
unmoralisch handeln wenn wir doch
eigentlich nie das unmoralische zum ziel
unseres handelns machen es wäre doch
irgendwie paradox
mir scheint der grund darin zu liegen
dass wir uns täuschen wenn wir moralisch
handeln
wir unterliegen einer täuschung wir
halten eben das falsche für das gute das
schlechte für das gute aber so dass wir
diese täuschung selbst zu verantworten
haben als ich mir ist ganz wichtig zu
betonen dass meine these dass diese
täuschung jetzt nicht einfach nur so und
defekt ist dass wir zu dumm sind wie wir
eben eine mathematikaufgabe nicht
richtig lösen können dass wir jetzt
einfach hier ein fehler nach kalkulation
betrieben haben und dann eigentlich
dachten wir hätten jetzt die richtige
lösung wir haben jetzt hier das gute
also angestrebt und dann haben wir halt
das falsche ergebnis raus bekommen also
haben am ende eben dann schlecht
gehandelt und dann können wir sagen ich
bin einfach zu dumm wenn man iq genügt
nicht als ich handle regelmäßig böse
obwohl ich eigentlich glaube dass gut zu
tun
ich glaube dass wir so dieses
selbsttäuschung nicht uns denken dürfen
weil wenn wir darauf verweisen würden
auf defekte vernunft wäre uns das jetzt
streng genommen dann so nicht mehr zu
rechnen war man müsste dann wieder
gründe anführen dafür dass wir eben den
fehler gemacht haben also du warst zu
unkonzentriert und so weiter und so fort
aber ich glaube auch dass so eine
beschreibung dem phänomen des
moralischen handelns nicht gerecht wird
die frage ist wie können wir uns auf ein
zurechenbare weise täuschen ist
täuschung nicht ein bloßer defekt und
jetzt hat immanuel kant auf den ich
jetzt hier so besonders eingehen möchte
bei dieser erklärung dieses phänomens
erstmal ganz interessante beobachtung
gemacht nämlich das phänomen der inneren
lüge also es geht jetzt um innere
phänomene innere lügen innere handlungen
in einer akte die ganz wichtig sind im
phänomen der selbst zwischen er sagt die
wirklichkeit mancher inneren lüge welche
die menschen sich zu schulden kommen
lassen zu beweisen ist leicht aber ihre
möglichkeit erklären scheint doch schwer
zu sein
weil eine zweite person dazu
erforderlich ist die man zu hintergehen
die absicht hat sich selbst aber
vorsätzlich zu betrügen einen
widerspruch in sich zu enthalten scheint
wer kann sich schon bewusst belügen doch
paradox wieso sollte man sich bewusst
mit
wenn ich genau weiß dass es falsch ist
wie sollte ich es dann noch tun
es geht auch so ein bisschen diese
richtung des sokratischen paradoxes navi
wie kann ich mich selbst so belegen dass
ich am ende glaube und auch noch danach
handle es doch eine lüge ist
und jetzt hat er donald davidson auch
hingewiesen auf ein paradox das ganz
ähnlich demokratischen paradox ist wie
wir zu irrationalen handlungen kommen
donald davidson formuliert es so weiter
geht nicht nur auf moralische 1 und ist
weiter er sagt die vorstellung von einer
irrationalen handlungen überzeugung
absicht folgerung oder gemütsregung ist
paradox denn das irrationale ist nicht
bloß das nicht rationale das außerhalb
des bereichs des rationalen liegt
sondern irrationalität ist ein versagen
innerhalb des hauses der vernunft also
es ist etwas was mit unserer rationalen
struktur selbst zu tun hat dass wir uns
selbst belügen als also nicht nur so ein
reiner defekt weiteres zitat von donald
davidson irrationalität tritt nur in
erscheinung wenn rationalität
offensichtlich am platz ist nämlich dort
wo sowohl ursache als auch willkommen
inhalte haben die in solchen logischen
beziehungen zueinander stehen die der
vernunft entgegenkommen oder deren
scheitern begünstigen ereignisse die nur
im hinblick auf ihre physikalischen oder
physiologischen eigenschaften aufgefasst
werden können nicht zur beurteilt werden
als seien sie gründe als stünden sie
miteinander in widerstreit oder
handelten von einem thema also es geht
dabei um den raum der gründe wenn wir
von selbsttäuschung von moralischem
handeln sprechen dann spielen musiker
physikalische oder physiologische
eigenschaften keine rolle
es geht um gründe die immer mit uns
rational i tät zu tun haben und jetzt
hat das was jetzt donner davidson hier
das versagen innerhalb des hauses der
vernunft genannt hat hier das hat
eigentlich viel früher schon immanuel
kant beschrieben wie mir scheint und er
hat dass die dialektik genannt die
dialektik der vernunft und kanten die
dialektik auch die logik des scheins
also ganz spannend das ist jetzt für
mich so ein schlüssel zum verständnis
dieses erzeugen von schein dieses sich
selbst belügen
was dennoch mit unserer vernunft zu tun
hat das also nicht nur so ein bloßer
defekt ist der auf unserer natürlichen
ausstattung gut und was sagt jetzt kann
über die dialektik sagt wir haben es mit
einer natürlichen und unvermeidlichen
illusion zu tun
die selbst auf subjektiven grundsätzen
beruht und sie als objektive unterschied
es gibt also eine natürliche und
unvermeidliche dialektik der reinen
vernunft nicht eine in die sich etwa ein
stümper durch mangel an kenntnissen
selbst verwickelt oder die irgendein so
fest um vernünftige leute zu verwirren
künstlicher sonnen hat sondern die der
menschlichen vernunft ohnehin deutlich
anhängt und selbst nachdem wie ihr
blendwerk aufgedeckt haben dennoch nicht
aufhören wird ihr vorzugaukeln und sie
unablässig in augenblickliche
verwirrungen zu stoßen die jederzeit
gehoben zu werden bedürfen also das ist
diesel diese problematik im haus der
vernunft unserer vernunft ist so
verfasst dass sie die tendenz hat
scheint zu erzeugen sich illusionen
hinzugeben und kant hat dieses schein
erzeugen mit blick auf die moralität auf
die frage nach der qualität unserer
handlungen mit dem begriff des
vernünftig bezeichnet das möchte ich
auch noch kurz vor lesen also das ist
wie ich finde eine sehr scharfsinnige
beobachtung die jetzt unsere unser
inneres seelenleben betrifft wie ich
später noch argumentieren werde unsere
inneren handlungen also äußere
handlungen werden nach kant immer
fundiert durch innere handlungen durch
innere verstrickungen wie ich es nenne
die erst andere handlungen äußere
handlung in ihrer
qualität möglich machen also kanzler
über das vernünftig
der mensch fühlt in sich selbst ein
mächtiges gegengewicht gegen alle gebote
der pflicht die ihm die vernunft zu
hochachtung würdig vorstellt an seinen
bedürfnissen und neigungen deren ganze
befriedigung unter dem namen der
glückseligkeit zusammenfasst wohngebiete
die vernunft ohne doch dabei den
neigungen etwas zu verheißen nachlass
lich mithin gleichsam mit zurücksetzung
und nichtachtung jener so unbestimmt und
dabei so billig scheinen ansprüche ihre
vorschriften und jetzt kommt hier aus
entspringt aber eine natürliche
dialektik hier kommt wieder der begriff
das heißt anhang wieder jene strenge
gesetze der pflicht zu vernünftigen und
ihre gültigkeit wenigstens ihre
einigkeit und strenge in zweifel zu
ziehen und sie womöglich unseren
wünschen und neigungen angemessener zu
machen das heißt sie im grunde zu
verderben und um ihre ganze würde zu
bringen welches denn doch selbst die
gemeinde praktische vernunft am ende
nicht gutheißen kann das was kann jetzt
hier vernünftig nennt kennt jeder
mit sicherheit nicht kenne sehr gut was
heißt von hövelmann sucht versucht sich
ausnahmen zu erlauben also eigentlich
ist das doch verboten
aber ich bin doch jetzt in einer solchen
situation und es gibt auch noch hier
diesen umständen und diesen umstand und
wenn ich es genau betrachtet müsste ich
doch angesichts dieser umstände diese
handlung doch tun dürfen eigentlich
nicht aber die konstellation der
umstände erlaubt ist und dann gibt es
noch diesen faktor und ich hab doch hier
noch dieses problem gehabt da hat mir
doch noch der unrecht getan und wenn ich
das alles mit hinein rechnen
dann komme ich am ende zu einem ergebnis
das ich gerechtfertigt bin diese
handlungen auszuführen
obwohl sie eigentlich nicht erlaubt ist
nach dem sittengesetz ich erlaube mir
eine ausnahme aber nicht einfach so dass
ich die ausnahme sondern ich begründe
sich rechtfertige diese ausnahme und
dieses rechtfertigen was man auch mit
dem geben und nehmen von gründen
beschreiben können ehrlich ich operiere
der ziemlich rational bin da ziemlich
intelligent bei diesen empfinden und
entdecken von ausnahmen das nennt kann
eben das vernünftig
das heißt da ist durchaus eine form von
rationalität ins spiel wenn wir uns
unmoralische maximen wie kann auch
unsere grundsätze nennt wählen das ist
nicht einfach nur so ein versagen
sondern das ist eine ganz schöne
aktivität da müssen wir ziemlich clever
sein ich glaube das kennt jeder von uns
diese aktivität und mir ist es wichtig
dass vernünftigen als eine innere
handlung darzustellen also das
vernünftig ist nicht nur so ein zustand
so modus befindlichkeit sondern es ist
eine innere aktivität eine operation
könnte man sagen und kann hat er nochmal
so zitat dazu setzt einen menschen der
demjenigen dessen not er sieht und dem
er leicht helfen kann nicht hilft hier
ist wie in dem herzen eines jeden
menschen so auch bei ihm ein positives
gesetz der nächstenliebe
dieses muss überwogen werden es gehört
hierzu eine wirkliche innere handlung
ausweg ursachen damit die unterlassung
möglich sein
das kostet auch wirklich einigen
menschen in anfang im merkliche mühe
einiges gutes zu unterlassen
wodurch sie positive antriebe in sich
bemerken die gewohnheit erleichtert
alles und diese handlung wird zuletzt
wenig mehr wahrgenommen
also hier muss wirklich anstrengungen
unternommen werden um unserem gewissen
unser mitleid solchen moralischen
gefühlen entgegen handeln zu können
je häufiger wird das tun die häufige wir
diese innere operation des vernünftiges
durch finden desto mehr gewöhnen wir uns
daran gewöhnen effekt wichtig ist mir
hier das kann von einer inneren handlung
spricht also nicht nur äußere handlung
dieses phänomen hier was kann beschreibt
dass wir dem anderen nicht hilft und
dass unser mitleid oder unsere
nächstenliebe nicht mehr wirkt das hatte
eigentlich davor schon groß so erkannt
sie kennen alle die unterscheidung von
amur proper und am oldesloer diese
eigenliebe die mit dem vernunft zustand
in die welt kommt und rousseau hat hier
ein zitat was ich ganz ganz ähnlich
finde also man kann seinen mitmenschen
unter seinem dem eigenen fenster
ungestraft umbringen hier der philosoph
von dem spricht hier
er braucht sich nur die ohren zuzuhalten
und sich ein paar argumente zurecht zu
legen um die natur die sich in ihm
empört daran zu hindern
mit dem zu identifizieren die man mit
links ermordet ob es so einfach ist weiß
ich nicht aber was hier so sagt ein paar
argumente zurechtlegen das scheint mir
genau das zu sein von dem kann mit dem
mit blick auf das vernünftige spricht
das ist die rationalisierung also unsere
vernunft schafft es offensichtlich
moralische impulse moralische erwägungen
auch letztendlich zu schwächen
und es ist ganz paradox wenn man doch
eigentlich denken sollte die vernunft
gebietet doch immer nur das gute die von
uns will doch immer nur auf das gute hin
offensichtlich gibt es eine tendenz der
vernunft geben in letzter konsequenz
dann auch zum unmoralischen zu führen
eine allein ich sage sich vernunft eine
dimension der rationalität ist fällt mir
sein also meine these ist unmoralische
handlungen im sinne dieser äußeren
handlung sind an innere handlungen
gebunden sind im inneren handlungen
fundiert und diese inneren handlungen
dies sind näher zu charakterisieren als
die operation des vernünftig als als
eine form des vernunft gebrauchs und je
komplexer die verstrickung des
vernünftiges also komplexer unsere
motivlage uns rechtfertigung strategien
wie komplexe dieses gespenst sag ich
jetzt mal von gründen die durch das
vernünftig markiert sind desto niedriger
die hemmschwelle und größe die gefahr
des moralischen handelns und der beste
fall ist in meinen augen dafür eben
terroristisches handeln das sind leute
die sich für besonders gut halten und
glauben dass besonders gute zu tun in
letzter konsequenz das beste zu tun und
die dann von einer handlung mehr
zurückschrecken und deren hemmschwelle
extrem niedrig ist und mir scheint dass
ideologien sich als kollektives positive
mit michel foucault jetzt gesprochen des
vernünftiges interpretieren lassen also
ideologien nehmen uns das vernünftig ab
sozusagen dann müssen wir selbst nicht
mehr uns gedanken machen sein ideologien
sind geronnene
aktie des geronnene innere handlungen
des vernünftiges kontinents wagen da ist
die rechtfertigung recht
fertigungsstruktur sagen wir mal logisch
fixiert und wir brauchen sie selbst
nicht mehr zu erbringen soll brauchen
sie nur noch nachzuvollziehen
und das sieht man bei allen großen
ideologien dass sie also schreckliches
zur folge hatten
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert also das ist
durchaus ein grund ideologie kritisch zu
sein weil eben hier rechtfertigung
strategien missbräuchlich dann
instrumentalisiert werden können
also man kann das ganze das mich damit
sagen man kann das ganze auch unabhängig
vom individuum jetzt sehen sondern auch
von inter subjektiven mit
gesellschaftlichen analyse her
betrachten und dann kommt man sehr
schnell auf totalitäre systeme das hat
an ahrens sehr schön gezeigt wie diese
strategien dann zu schrecklichen taten
führen können
wichtig ist mir zu betonen dass das
letztlich einfach nur dummheit ist sind
das da ziemlich viel gedanken mit eine
rolle spielen also unser denken ist
durchaus problematisch und so denken ist
nicht nur auf das gute gerichtet und
deswegen hat auch bettina stangneth vor
zwei jahren ein sehr gutes buch
geschrieben mit dem titel böses denken
damit ist einmal gemeint man kann an
etwas böses denken oder das böse
bedenken aber auch das denken selbst
kann böse sein und dieses böse ding ist
eben gerade in ideologien oder im
phänomen des kooperation des
vernünftiges enthalten
jetzt möchte ich abschließend noch ein
paar auswege aus diesem von den sternen
aufzeigen es scheint ja so dass wir da
gar nicht mehr raus kommen also wenn
jetzt die die rationalität uns praktisch
als solche auch eine falle stellen kann
oder missbraucht werden kann
wie kommen wir denn dann raus aus diesem
vernünftig und auch hier ist mein
bezugspunkt immanuel kant der hat in
seiner kritik der urteilskraft drei
regeln des gesunden menschenverstandes
aufgestellt den zensus kommunist also
hier wieder an eine form der
rationalität plädiert und er sagt er
gibt jetzt drei regeln die möchte jetzt
kurz vorstellen
die offensichtlich dieses vernünftigen
vermeiden helfen sollen selbst zu denken
mit dem selbst regen hat so seine
schwierigkeiten auf sich weil ist denn
vernünftig nicht auch selbst denken
jetzt kann man natürlich vor allem gut
verläuft dann ist nicht denken aber das
leuchtet mir nicht ein und könnte man
sagen ja selbst zu denken wenn man
vernünftig denkt man nicht selbst aber
das leuchtet mir nicht ein
also kann sagt ja auch nicht dass das
allein das ist er bringt ja 3 das zweite
scheint mir noch viel wichtiger zeichnen
sich an der stelle eines anderen zu
denken
das scheint mir so eine möglichkeit es
sein aus dieser inneren zirkular i tät
des vernünftiges das ist glaube ich auch
ein charakteristikum wir drehen uns nur
um und selbst im vernünftig und martin
luther hat das mal genannt im anschluss
an augustinus dieses inkubators in sebs
um all dieses in sich selbst hinein
gekrümmte sind ausdruck von martin
luther also dieses diese eigenen
bezogenheit die da in vernünftiger neben
auftritt es geht nur um mich und mir
wurde unrecht getan und hier habe ich
wieder ein rechtfertigungsgrund und das
rechtfertigt jetzt das und dass das kann
man versuchen es vermeiden indem man
sich eben mal in die stille eines
anderen denkt scheint mir als sehr
hilfreich zu sein und dann noch
jederzeit mit sich selbst einstimmig zu
denken das finde ich wieder so ein
bisschen schwierig weil vernünftigen hat
doch auch diese einstimmigkeit also
vernünftig erzeugt doch auch so eine
kohärenz sag ich jetzt mal das denken
also ich mir scheint besonders wichtig
seien der zweite punkt sich an die
stelle eines anderen zu denken wie wäre
es denn jetzt bin ich der wäre hätte der
oder die dann nicht auch genau dieselben
gründe so zu denken wie ich wenn ich mir
diese option anschaue dann müsste ich
meine eigenen gedanken relativieren
es geht ja um selbst relativierung
externalisierung das ist glaube ich die
entscheidende punkt der uns da helfen
kann
aus diesem aus dieser verstrickung aus
diesem teufelskreis der inneren
verkrümmung die unsere vernunft uns auch
erlaubt herauszutreten und dann im
letzte hinsicht solche schrecklichen
unmoralischen oder auch bösen taten zu
vermeiden
sagt kann die kritiker urteilskraft ich
möchte jetzt am schluss noch auf ein
netzwerk hinweisen formen des
unmoralischen skizzieren kooperation
auch mit dem mk
herr dr heiliger ist freundlicherweise
auch mitglied hat er mir gesagt herr und
frau professor wechsel auch also wir
werden uns hier mit diesen formen hier
weiter befassen und ich wünsche ihnen
noch alles gute